so a bunch of redditors on wall street
bets have coordinated to inflate the
stock price of
gamestop trying to basically bankrupt a
hedge fund that has the opposite
position
who cares yolo but is this
legal well generally you can't conspire
to set the price of anything let alone
stock and they're generally two types of
things the sec
really likes to put a stop on one is
fraud you can't lie about a stock to try
and inflate the price
and two is what's called market
manipulation illegal market manipulation
is defined as to affect the loan or with
one or more other persons a series of
transactions
and any security creating actual or
apparent active trading in such security
or raising or depressing the price of
such security for the purpose of
inducing the purchase or sale of such
security by others
market manipulation is a very squishy
term that's very hard to decide because
often you're buying a stock hoping that
others will buy it as well and inflate
the price but just because a bunch of
predators are doing it for the lulls
doesn't mean
it's not illegal it depends and this one
could go either way and that's why you
should only buy orange juice concentrate
pork bellies and gold bullion
and i'll see you in court